I am thrilled to bring to the stage to
talk about his principles for innovation
to have a conversation about where the
Media Lab is going where innovation is
going my boss Joey Ito thanks even so
you and John told me two different
things to say so I'll mix the two T yeah
so welcome to the Media Lab the Media
Lab was founded next year it'll be 30
years so if you remember 30 years ago
well there was a rudimentary version of
the Internet it was mostly to connect
supercomputers together and it was
before the Macintosh it was sort of
before we had social media anything like
that so the Media Lab was very dedicated
back then to empowering the individual
so a lot of taking these desktop CAD cam
systems and putting it into personal
computers empowering the individual
through sort of man-machine interface
coming up with things like multi-touch
and Kindle and stuff like that so Somy
lab has traditionally been kind of a
human-computer interface and a rather
sort of thing and software oriented
place Niklas famously wrote a book
called being digital about how the world
was turning I'm digital and we have the
Center for bits and atoms so that
interface between bits and nanos was
another thing about the lab so roll
forward 30 years what's changed was
changes that we finished or at least had
to make a lot of progress in empowering
the individual connecting the individual
and so now we have a network and
suddenly when you start looking about
looking at things as a network you have
to think about things as systems instead
of objects and it's less about
empowering individual and more about
empowering the community so suddenly the
by the Media Lab my interpretation of
Media Lab media is plural for medium and
medium is something in which you can
express yourself and the expression in
the past was things like hardware and
displays and robots but as the medium of
what we're expressing ourselves in
becomes society and the ecosystem and
journalism suddenly the work that we're
doing which is always very applied
looks much more like social science like
applied social science things like like
journalism and less like fiddling on
with things on the screen so I think I
would divide my life and I think that
divide the media labs life into sort two
phases there's before the internet which
I call bi life was simple things were
sort of relatively predictable
economists were even sometimes able to
predict things and then there's after an
in it where life becomes extremely
complex unpredictable and it's more
about systems and it's more about how do
you participate responsibly in a system
that you can't predict and whose outcome
to your intervention is really kind of
almost random and so so that that's sort
of where we have to meeting up however
there's some core DNA at the Media Lab
that's sort of stayed the same which is
we're we're very practice and build
oriented in the old days Nikolas used to
say in the old days until recently they
used to say here demo or die I'm Nikolas
famously said the demo only has to work
once because our main pathway to impact
was getting big companies to see the
demos and become inspired to build
things like guitar hero or Mindstorms or
whatever they would get inspired
actually a lot of the stuff in the
original Macintosh came from things here
but today now that the Internet has
happened I've changed it to deploy or
Die which is that we want our students
and faculty to think about how we touch
the real world directly and let me
describe a little bit about the dynamics
of why I think that's more true than
ever so if you think about the internet
so the internet as a technology and as a
set of protocols allowed hackers like me
and others to build Internet Service
Providers is the first time an
entrepreneur to compete with the
telephone companies and connectivity is
because of the open standards and we've
been talking about internet being open
but the protocol of the Internet itself
is open so that me and a bunch of used
hardware could create a point of
presence and give access to people to
connect to each other and so suddenly
what used to cost thousands and
thousands of dollars
started to cost nearly zero because
there was a forced diminishing of price
as a competition drove the price to
nearly zero and what that means is the
distribution costs the collaboration
cost the communication costs went nearly
to zero
this allowed things like free and open
source software to completely dominate
especially in the back-end space that
combined with Moore's law creates an
extremely low cost of building computer
system so before the internet if you
want to build a communication system
there were a lot back then video tech
systems like mini tel and captain in
Japan you build the network you build
the hardware you build the software you
build up a system you get the content it
costs billions of dollars to build these
network systems they took forever to
construct and they didn't work what
happened now is if you think about
Facebook Yahoo Google all these guys
they bought an off-the-shelf PC or built
one themselves but a bunch of free
software in it wrote a little few
algorithms and then plugged it into the
network and it would run so what used to
cost billions of dollars or hundreds of
millions of dollars cost nearly nothing
in that it just costs some sweat equity
and a couple kids in a dorm room and so
you had these kids competing with
incumbents and what that I would call
that is innovation cost or the cost of
trying a thing went from hundreds of
millions of dollars to nearly zero so
what that does is it takes the
innovation the ability to try something
from large institutions that have
Authority and money so says let's take
journalism so in the in the old days if
you want to put something on video you
had to have a studio and big expensive
cameras and a satellite transponder or
something to transmit the things into
the air way so it was it a lot of
capital if you want to be a publisher
you had to have a printing press if you
wanted to be on the radio you had to
have a radio station so everything costs
money which means you had to raise money
which means you had to get it from
somebody so it usually meant you had to
make a proposal or if you were in a
company you had to get permission and so
what the internet has or provided was an
ability for people to innovate without
asking permission because they didn't
need money and what that did was it
pushed so all of the great come
in Silicon Valley these days started
after the internet the ones that started
after then it's almost all of them
started without any in capital so that's
why we lost this this Annalee saxenian
book regional advantage which is about
how innovation shifted from Boston to
Silicon Valley a lot of this had to do
with the fact that the kids out there
didn't need permission and everybody
over here was used to getting permission
and granting permission as sort of a key
component and it also I always call it
was MBA innovation because you had to
sort of have an MBA to be able to raise
a hundred million dollars but now it's
designer innovation or engineering
innovation where you don't need the MBA
until you're going public so so what
what the diminishing cost of innovation
did was to push innovation to the edges
and then allowed a kind of grassroots
innovation so and I'm using the word
innovation kind of broadly but we see
that here at the Media Lab as well so
you know if you want to create hardware
it used to be that you had to have a big
company to create hardware but now we
have startups like form labs and little
bits and everywhere we have you know
half a dozen Hardware status coming out
of the Media Lab that was sort of
unheard of a few generations ago so so
the diminishing cost of innovation
allows research that's being done here
to go past just the demo phase into
deployment you can create a website that
millions of people can see you can
create hardware that can be distributed
it is interesting to know however though
that commercial startups aren't the best
thing for some ideas because in a way
Nicholas though is so Nicholas
Negroponte and I disagree on this he
says startups can't have any big ideas
which I don't think is true some
startups do have big ideas but some is't
but I have an iteration and his critique
which is some big ideas don't work in
startups because you need to invest
decades of time or you need to think
about it in a very non commercial way or
you need to take a lot of risk that a
funder wouldn't take so in that sense I
think you do need an academic
institution to shield researchers from
the necessity of providing a business
plan or a business model and give them
time to think about it and when you map
it on to journalism I think it's also
there's a interesting parallel so you
know we have a night news challenge and
we have a whole bunch of really amazing
projects
where you're all out in the world
building things because the cost of
innovation is so cheap and it turns out
if you'd like the safecast story even
the hardware is actually you know
citizen science doable you didn't need
to raise a bunch of money a small grant
from foundation get you kick-started but
then there are certain things like
sending a whole bunch of journalists
into Syria or doing data science that
requires years and years and lots and
lots of computing iron that don't really
work with a little bit of grant money or
a little bit of startup and I think
that's sort of the chasm that's
happening in journalism where you know
Simon the New York Times board and one
of the things they did to sort of
indoctrinated me they send you home with
a pile of all the Pulitzer Prize
nominations right so it's not just the
winner just all of them it's like this
and every single one you read it's like
a year of some journalists time saving
dozens of people's lives or taking down
a corrupt politician and most of them
only occur because you have the power of
the legal office of the New York Times
defending you and you may have to have
military support going into a space
these are not things that citizen
journalists are easily going to do but
the business model of traditional
journalism is challenged we'll see
whether the business model of higher ed
is going to be challenged but but I
think what's what's interesting is there
are certain things that we can solve
from this kind of rapid bottom-up agile
innovation which I think we're getting
better at but there are certain types of
things that seem to be a little bit
harder and so we need to kind of think
about what the business model is now it
could be that startups like Kickstarter
for instance I think is a pretty
interesting start I'm an investor but
and I just say that as a disclosure not
as a boast although I guess it I guess I
guess it turns out to be both but but
you know there are certain models that
may turn out to be big ideas coming out
from small companies and I think there's
some sort of sweet SWOT that we're
trying to find here and so now putting
on my knight Foundation hat what's
interesting when you think about how
money flows so in the old days when it
used to cost a hundred million dollars
or even ten million dollars to fund a
software idea the guys who had the money
had the power because entrepreneurs just
needed money before they could actually
do any
things so the sort of exaggerating here
but the the venture capitalists used to
kick back and say all right pitch me
your idea you know and and the people
who had the money kind of were a little
bit arrogant and expected a full-blown
impressive presentation these days
because the cost of trying something is
so cheap there isn't enough space for
everybody to get in for the first round
and a lot of these entrepreneurs go
ahead and start their companies without
even talking to the venture capitalist
so the venture capitalists are having to
sort of claw their way into little deals
present how they're going to be so
helpful because in order for them to put
real money and later in the company they
have to have been helpful upfront or
they have to get into the deal upfront
now obviously you know they're there
it's a seller's market for a particular
category of deals but but but
fundamentally if you have a track record
you have a good company the venture
capitalists are going to be trying a lot
harder to get into the deal because
there's just a lot less deal and a lot
less money that they need similarly I
think in foundations is sort of similar
right so if I'm a foundation it used to
be you know that you would get and we
still get but you used to get big
institutions like the Opera of X Y Z
saying we need years of operating
support and you'd say okay well and you
take a year of trying to figure out
whether you want to put the money in and
then you get your name on the building
and it was pretty straightforward now
you've got hundreds of ideas you want to
get into the thing and so as Knight
Foundation I think we should be doing
this and we I think we are is we convene
meetings we try to explain why you
should take Knight Foundation money
rather than venture startup money or
this other person's money because you're
joining a community and we have value
and if our program officers aren't
adding value to the organizations that
we're giving money to I don't think
we're doing our job that's how we're
trying to pick the best people this is
create a community which I think you all
are and and so so I think in in in the
sense that the diminishing cost of
innovation is making people who have
money behave a little better I think
it's a good thing but we still have the
same problem so we do the night news
challenge we come with a lot of ideas
but I do sometimes wonder well who's
thinking about those ideas that don't
start small and how should we think
about some of the bigger problems and I
think in a way part of it is also
thinking about as a community because
when you think about a system so for
instance I boasts again I was a investor
in Twitter and when we invested in
Twitter I remember a lot of people say
that's the stupidest company its
investment it's not a company it's a
feature and what was interesting about
that was it turns out that if Twitter
were in the days before internet well it
would be stupid actually have a faculty
member here at the Media Lab who who
shouted at me when I was interviewing I
invented Twitter 30 years ago and I said
well it was pretty useless 30 years ago
because you didn't have anything to link
to right it's all a useful when you're
in a system and so similarly one idea
that I have about tackling the big
problems is if you think about it all of
us as an ecosystem all of you as pieces
of the ecosystem each of you are working
on certain problems within the ecosystem
but then to think about it as an
ecosystem can the ecosystem solve the
big problems and it's a complex system
with no one really in charge but at but
somehow we should be able to think about
things at that level so so this is where
it gets to another piece of the Media
Lab which is I'd like to think about the
future of design and so in the old days
in the old days some people still do
this when you design something you kind
of design it for one particular purpose
and it's like you're building a thing
but when the world is complex into the
system design is gonna feel a lot more
like life like growing like giving birth
to a child in an environment that you
don't have control of so you don't know
exactly where that child is gonna go and
that child has your DNA but hopefully it
turns into something that you're going
to be proud of and I think that if
everybody does that and is sort of
responsible you end up with a community
that's actually pretty functional that
generally heads in the trajectory that
you want things to go and I kind of feel
like the solution to the maternal ism
idea the solution to the Civic's idea of
the solution to the government idea is
not going to be some brilliant uh I got
it
it's going to be some combination of
pieces in a network that sort of start
to become resilient start to grow and
turn into a thing and for that I think
the open Internet that you we've been
talking about all all these last two
days is essential because as those
people who try to close a system go in
there it's really like
gunking up an ecosystem with pollution
trash or constraints that you don't
really want and so I think that that's
if you think about it as a gardener I
think the open Internet is the water the
openness the air that you need and then
I think all of us are the organisms that
live there to try to make this thing
vibrant can I get the principle slide up
now so so so these are some principles
that I've been working on and a lot of
people disagree with a lot of them but I
don't care and I will I guess I yeah I I
care about the arguments I don't care
that they're disagreeing but you know
this is in a complex system this is sort
of the way I think you need to think
about it instead of this sort of
Newtonian Euclidian laws of before
Internet when you could predict things I
think you sort of have to live very much
it's sort of a Zen thing it's more about
being present and about thinking about
things in this way I think so so for
instance to take the lower left on
learning over education I know Bracken
hates this one but to me education is
what people do to you and learning is
what you do to yourself and like an
education like you have you completed
your education yes I have a degree I'm
done well no that's not it's pretty
useless what you want is you want to
learn how to learn and continue to learn
so in a lot of education is about the
degree so if when the first year PhD
students come to the Media Lab I often
say pretend that at the end of your
degree program I take your degree away
and says psych I want you to have be
able to look back and say it was still
worth it I don't want you to be at the
Media Lab because you want to get out
because by the way the media arts and
sciences degree that you get here isn't
there are no jobs listed for media arts
and science PhDs turns out it's not like
engineering so so I think part of it is
learning is should be the focus not the
education disobedience over compliance I
think this is also a tricky one for a
lot of our faculty members but you don't
win a Nobel Prize by doing what you're
told you win a Nobel Prize by
questioning Authority and thinking for
yourself and I think if you're trying to
create an institution that's resilient
to the computerization and the robot
ization of the world you don't want a
whole bunch of
people doing exactly the same thing as
everybody else
in a predictable in order to leave away
well guess what talk about education we
are trying to train kids to produce
exactly the same answers as you expect
not to ask questions and to do be
disobedient but I think what you want is
you want to create a system or an
organization that's resilient to
disobedience and I think a lot of the
projects here are really about being I
mean a lot of civics is about
disobedience emergence over Authority
this just means how does the authority
of a system exist
and if you look at open-source projects
if you look at communities Authority
tends to be emergent right so if you
look at the heads of a lot of the
successful open-source projects they
tend to be somewhat quiet people who
have a lot of EQ who aren't naturally
trying to grasp power but end up in
power because everybody the followers
push them they're to me the authority is
the opposite where somebody comes in
with a title and based on the title is
so if you're in a system like an
investment bank where everybody's trying
to claw up to the top all you need is
sort of a club in order to manage the
system because there's this natural
incentive that money is pulling people
to stay but when you're in a system
where people are paying to participate
or volunteering to participate like many
of the nonprofit's then what you want is
you want this sort of emergent Authority
which is I think really important
compass over maps I think is kind of
ties to the big idea versus a little
idea problem which is I think you need
to have a compass heading of where you
want to go like what we use the safecast
example we want to figure out this
radiation problem but every step of the
way we were trying to figure out what we
were doing and we couldn't have mapped
it out and now from the map costs more
to build then it's worth because the
complexity is so high and it's so
unpredictable so I think there's a
dependence on planning I think is really
a weakness and it ties to this risk over
safety things so for example the first
ISP that I set up in Japan or the ISP I
set up in Japan I tried to raise money
for at six hundred thousand dollars I
took it to a big company in Japan and
they spent three million dollars on
consultants to come up with a study not
to invest six hundred thousand dollars
so if it costs you more money to think
about it than to do it
probably better to do it and it turns
out if you do it you get a fact not a
theory so they had a three million
dollar theory when I could have given
him a $600,000 fact even if I were wrong
and so so I think that ties to this
practice over theory so I think it's
really important to do things especially
when the cost of doing things is cheaper
than the cost of talking about it and
trying to decide whether to do it or not
and a lot of times it works in practice
and not in theory which is fine because
then you can figure out the theory later
most of the world is dealing with stuff
that works in theory but not in practice
and they're trying to discredit reality
in order to fit with their theory and
but in theory they say theory and
practice are the same and then pull over
push again I'll keep using the safecast
model to see Shawn here is really the
idea that you pull from the network as
you need it rather than stalking and
centrally controlling it so in safecast
we started after the earthquake but we
beat I said beat we were more effective
than any NGO or government that had
planned and spent millions of dollars
before the earthquake because we were
able to find what we needed when we
needed it and it turns out that way we
found better partners and and it cost
less and it retained our agility and
agility is what comes out of that
because if you have printing presses and
lines of code and IP those are all
reasons not to shift course and stick to
your map rather than the compass and and
you know and and all the things that we
think are assets actually are
liabilities when you think about it from
the perspective of agility so the power
pole is really as you if you only
pulling things that you need as you go
you can move very quickly and you have a
lot of agility I'm not going to go over
the others because there's somewhat
obvious but I think what I'll do now is
is to switch to a conversation and some
questions thank you
and comments are fine too if you
somebody want to dislike others there
you talked about the media innovation
ecosystem and one of the great values of
a conference like this is we can find
out what's going on there some way that
Civic media could map real-time the
innovation that is taking place globally
so that we're all kind of we're not
reinventing the wheel we can sort of
share our experiences and pull faster so
I'm gonna defer this question to Michael
because that's what he should be doing
but I think that's a good point I think
that trying to figure out how to
communicate I think so I think you're
right the conference is a great system I
think a lot of people have experimented
with ways to try to share knowledge but
it seems to be one of the hardest
problems because everyone's gonna day
job they're very busy and people have
slightly different languages and when
you're face to face you can kind of
coordinate your language in real time
but when you sort of separate things out
it gets really difficult and and this is
actually an interesting there's an
interesting parallel on the web of the
Semantic Web people who are trying to
create a sort of card catalog of
everything and then there are other
people who love tagging and kind of the
sloppiness and just use search and and
this sort of coordination inside of an
ecosystem I think it actually is also
there's an interesting parallel to just
general governance and civics as well
which is how do you get a bunch of
people who are working on stuff I'm
coordinated you know we at the Media Lab
we do have several different approaches
you know we have this sort of big data
data mining machine learning so you know
work like predicting things through sort
of causalities and patterns versus
something where people are more in
charge and people are more activist I
think it's a rich domain I don't think
we've figured it out but I hope that
Michael will talk about a little bit
during his comments thank you you have
an interesting couple of positions that
give you
perspective on journalism your role with
the knight foundation as well as being
on the board of the New York Times what
do you think of the way the business
models are evolving in journalism what
do you think about the way the business
ecosystem is evolving and sort of where
do you think business models are going
in journalism so I think that's that is
that's sort of the million dollar or not
million billion dollar question I don't
I don't I don't think I want to say that
I have a view in terms of what's gonna
actually work I think that there are so
many variables that are moving and it's
pretty unpredictable and so what I would
do and that that's why I'm on the knight
Foundation board and at the Media Lab
and at the New York Times I think we
have to try everything I think there's a
possibility that the traditional media
companies kind of figure something out
and then there's a paid model the
advertising off mobile there's a whole
bunch of models that we're trying at the
New York Times some more successfully
than others I think that the night news
challenge is trying that the point of of
that and some of our prototype funding
is to really try to see if we can find a
business model somewhere the good news I
don't know if it's good news the news is
that the news folks
like New York Times and Financial Times
all of us realize that we're in a moment
of crisis and that if somebody figures
it out it's going to help everybody so
the good news is we I saw Matt Carroll
here there he is he said he's heading
the the news initiative at the Media Lab
and it's interesting the extent to which
the news companies are willing to get
together to talk about the future of the
business model as well as a feature of
editorial so there's a lot of
cooperation more than you would normally
expect but I think the the jury's still
out on what it is and I think we have to
try everything until we figure it out so
it's a sort of a non-answer but but let
me know hi Joey thank you for this slide
I watched you put it up in about two
dozen cameras went up to take pictures
so there must be some magic here I want
to ask though personally which of these
you struggle with the most
why struggle with it in terms of it's
difficult for me correct I guess this
one that I struggle with the most is you
know in a funny way let's see well
they're all tricky different ways I
think resilience over strength is sort
of an interesting one which is what I
mean by that one is instead of trying to
sort of bulk up and resist failure
invest the same money on recovery and
resilience and when you're running an
institution when you're trying to build
stuff you you you tend to want to invest
in trying to and it's related to the
risk over safety trying to minimize
failure rather than trying to work on
resilience and this is also if it is
kind of a Zen thing too right so so if
you're extremely present and ready for
anything you're an extremely resilient
state and so if you get shoved you you
you wobble but you come back and if
you're not present you're always focused
on the future and the past you end up
trying to build walls and and and trying
to make sure that you don't get shoved
and and it's it's it's hard because when
you're surrounded by other planners in
an institution like this you tend to
sort of focus on structure which is
really kind of the strength versus
resilience structure versus this serve
on Cena sand and I and again I think
that on the internet a lot of the pieces
are very resilient but when you're in an
institution that's used to be a lot of
planning it um it's it's hard to create
that interface